in the southern French city of Toulouse
the future has arrived even if it might
not look like it at first glance airbus
has its headquarters here and the
airplane manufacturer is taking part in
an international congress in the city at
the event hi Kinneret has brought
together representatives from science
and industry he's collected around a
billion euros for the European research
initiative graphene flagship its goal is
to explore uses for the high-tech
material which is highly conductive and
practically invisible so you're telling
me that there's graphene here there is
graphene layer here demonstrates our
Emperor's New Clothes so there is a
graphene layer behind the poster that
when we touch we can we can detect the
touch on the graphene layer all the
leads have been created with a graphene
ink graphene is a one atom thick layer
of carbon incredibly thin yet extremely
tough that makes it the perfect material
for Aeronautics applications in the
1950s plastic revolutionized the
industry scientists expect graphene to
do that in the 21st century physics
nobel laureate Arbor fair is also
convinced the material as a bright
future I am excited by many topics in
physics but graphene is exciting and
after this meeting I become a little
more excited in revolution is a big word
I think evolution is much nicer but of
course graphene is a disruptive change
so in some areas you will have to make
small revolutions to move forward like
in the aviation industry Laurent Ivana
has more than 30 years experience with
tough but ultralight construction
materials in the business they lower
fuel consumption and resist where
although he sees graphene's promise he's
still a little scamp
about time frames graphene is very a
very early beginning and I know that for
the scientist is very promising but
promising for our business is not enough
you know that means when the when you
would like to get a technology on an
aircraft it has to be available almost
10 years before any application and five
years before it has to be on the shelf
that means graphene is probably
something good for the next decades but
today I cannot answer at all what can be
the future that
so maybe the revolution won't be
spreading from Toulouse to every corner
of the world just yet but that hasn't
dampened the enthusiasm surrounding the
high-tech material garage Kinneret has
helped organize the events first
graphene workshop for representatives
from industry they can make their
expectations clear to researchers while
scientists have an opportunity to
explain what's currently possible and
what's not in the US and asia
researchers entrepreneurs and
policymakers are already cooperating to
turn lab results into products the
graphene gold rush has begun and
European researchers are up against some
stiff competition China and very
recently has started to invest quite a
lot of money in graphene I don't know
the exact numbers but when you look for
instance in patent applications there
are a lot of patent applications coming
from China there are a lot of articles
published by the Chinese researchers so
in terms of a quantity they are very
good but not all of them have very high
quality high rise buildings could be
built using graphene someday the
material could make computers faster and
more powerful but it will take a lot
more research and many more conferences
before the material is used on a wide
scale the event in toulouse has done its
part to help it along europe is
definitely part of the international
race to explore the many potential uses
of graphene
you